el siguiente problema fue tomado del
libro cuyos autores son cots trainer y
townsend y que en español se llamaría
algo así como química y reactividad
química y este problema dice supongamos
que quieres conocer el cambio en la en
tal pie entonces este va a ser un
problema de cambio en tal vía para la
formación del metano cuya fórmula
química que está es ch4 y esta reacción
se da a partir de carbono sólido que
está en su forma de grafito e hidrógeno
gaseoso ok entonces aquí nos dan nuestra
reacción y nos piden calcular el cambio
en la entropía
además nos dicen el cambio en la en tal
vía para esta reacción no puede ser
medida en el laboratorio debido a que la
reacción es muy lenta ok entonces a lo
mejor éste lo que ocurre es que la
reacción es tan lenta que uno no puede
medir con un pues no se no puede medir
con ningún instrumento de forma digamos
consistente o clara cuánto calor o
cuánta energía se despide o se absorbe
en esta reacción pues nos dice sin
embargo podemos medir el cambio en la en
tal vía para la combustión del carbono
hidrógeno y metano ok entonces
inmediatamente cuando cuando nos dicen
que por qué podemos calcularla entalpía
de otras reacciones y de hecho aquí nos
dan verdad estamos haciendo combustión
del carbono en su forma de grafito del
hidrógeno en forma gaseosa y del metano
estas tres reacciones donde en realidad
son reacciones de combustión tienen
cierto camión entalpía y cuando nos dan
este tipo de información inmediatamente
tu cerebro debe decir este
un problema en donde hay que utilizar la
ley de hesse muy bien y que es
esencialmente lo que nos dice la ley de
gs nos dice cómo obtener el cambio en la
antártida a partir del cambio de la
entropía de otras reacciones muy bien
nos dice esencialmente que el cambio si
esta reacción la podemos escribir
digamos como una suma de estas
reacciones entonces el cambio en la
entalpía de esta reacción será igual a
la suma de estos cambios en la entropía
muy bien entonces la pregunta esencial
aquí es como obtenemos esta reacción a
partir de estas otras muy bien y eso va
a ser principalmente todo el problema
que hay que resolver así que vamos a
empezar primero con este producto
tenemos el metano vamos a empezar con el
metano y veamos en donde en estas
reacciones se encuentra pues
esencialmente se encuentra aquí el
metano verdad entonces el problema es
que nuestra reacción original el metano
es un producto mientras que aquí el
metano es uno
así que vamos a tratar de escribir esta
reacción donde tal suerte que el metano
ahora sea solo un producto y eso
esencialmente es cambiar el sentido de
esta flecha verdad entonces vamos a
vamos vamos a reescribir lo si yo quiero
que el metano sea un producto lo que
tengo que hacer es escribir la reacción
inversa tengo el dióxido de carbono en
su forma gaseosa y vamos a ponerlo con
varios colores
dos moles o dos moléculas de agua en su
forma líquida esto ahora nos va a dar
nos va a dar dos moléculas de oxígeno
gaseoso este es el oxígeno gaseoso y
además una molécula de metano ok
entonces esencialmente reescribe esta
reacción pero en sentido contrario y por
supuesto si yo es esta reacción no se va
a dar de forma espontánea para que se
pudiera llevar a cabo esto requeriría
mucha energía y por lo tanto lo que
podemos ver es que nuestro camión la
entalpía nuestro cambio en lenta al pie
de esta reacción va a ser pues si si si
esta reacción desprendía energía
recordemos que si el camión entalpía es
negativa quiere decir que hubo menos
energía final que la inicial y entonces
en realidad esta es una reacción
exotérmica verdad así que este cambio la
entalpía como ahora vamos en sentido
contrario pues necesitamos energía así
que esto va a ser
890 punto 3 kilo jules por mol para que
para esta reacción muy bien para esta
reacción entonces vamos a ver al menos
para suerte nuestra el metano ya está
del lado de los productos pero fíjense
muy bien en la reacción original siempre
hay que tener en mente a dónde queremos
llegar entonces necesitamos carbono y
dos moléculas de hidrógeno gaseoso
verdad para obtener metano pero antes de
obtener meta no necesito dióxido de
carbono y agua como podríamos obtener el
dióxido de carbono y el agua bueno pues
si nos fijamos en las otras dos
reacciones nos dice justamente la
primera nos dice carbono si lo juntamos
bueno si lo ponemos a reaccionar con
oxígeno nos da dióxido de carbono que es
uno de mis primeros reactivos después si
yo tengo el hidrógeno y el oxígeno van a
reaccionar y formar agua y justo es el
otro reactivo que yo necesito para que
se lleve a cabo esta reacción y más aún
los reactivos de estas dos ecuaciones
son carbono en su estado en su estado
sólido que es el grafito y el hidrógeno
en su estado gaseoso entonces realmente
tenemos aquí ya toda la información que
necesitamos solo voy a empezar a
escribirlo tenemos el carbono en su
estado sólido
más ya teníamos un color para el oxígeno
más una molécula de oxígeno gaseoso nos
debe dar co2 es decir dióxido de carbono
hoy estaba en verde un mono o una
molécula de dióxido de carbono y el
cambio en lenta al pie de esta reacción
el cambio en la entropía de esta
reacción es de menos 390 y 3.5 kilos
jules por mol para esta reacción
ok entonces esto por supuesto nos dice
que es una reacción exotérmica y si
tiene sentido pues estamos esencialmente
haciendo combustión de algo pues va a
liberar energía verdad y por otro lado
necesitamos esta reacción h2 creo que no
tengo color para el hidrógeno vamos a
ponerlo con azul tengo hidrógeno gaseoso
medio mol por supuesto son moles verdad
no podemos hablar de media molécula
medio mol de oxígeno gaseoso nos da como
resultado agua que es h2o un molde de
agua muy bien entonces si nos fijamos en
nuestra ecuación original
yo quiero carbono más dos moléculas de
hidrógeno gaseoso que aquí los tenemos
verdad pero para que tengamos dos
moléculas de hidrógeno gaseoso
necesitamos multiplicar por 2 esta
reacción es decir aquí vamos a
multiplicar por 12 para que tengamos dos
moléculas y si yo multiplico por dos
esto pues simplemente se cancela el un
medio verdad y tendremos dos moles de
agua muy bien entonces ya estamos
llegando justamente a donde queremos
para determinar esta reacción
o más bien el cambio en lenta al día de
esta reacción para eso primero vamos a
notar cuál es el cambio en lenta lpi a
para la reacción esta de aquí
y esto simplemente era déjenme ver pues
bueno si tenemos que para la reacción
original es menos 280 y 5.8 kilo jules
por mol para esta reacción entonces como
en realidad estamos realizando esta
reacción dos veces vamos a multiplicar
por dos vamos a sacar la calculadora
ahí lo tienen entonces tenemos que
multiplicar por 2 menos 2 280 y 5.8
entonces tenemos menos 280 y 5.8 por 2 y
eso nos da menos 570 y 1.6 así que esta
reacción requiere menos 570 y 1.6 kilo
jules por mol para esta reacción muy
bien entonces está nuevamente pues
vuelve a hacer una combustión y es muy
fácil de intuir que se va a liberar
energía verdad es exotérmica ahora bien
vamos a ver esta última reacción la boya
la voy a en realidad necesitamos estos
dos para después producir bióxido de
carbono y agua y tener finalmente el
metano verdad entonces vamos a ponerlo
en orden déjenme copiar y pegar esto
de hecho vamos a cortarlo
vamos a rellenar el esto con negro ok
entonces y ahora lo pegamos vamos a
ponerlo al final porque este es el orden
que llevan la reacción es verdad primero
necesitamos el carbono con el oxígeno
para dar dióxido de carbono
paralelamente necesitamos el hidrógeno y
el oxígeno para formar el agua y ya que
están estos dos formados podemos crear
el oxígeno más metano muy bien entonces
vamos a ver qué tanto se cancela en
estas reacciones que tanto se obtiene y
demás ok entonces primero nosotros
tenemos un dióxido de carbono tenemos un
dióxido de carbono en los productos que
después se va a utilizar en los
reactivos muy bien después tenemos dos
aguas que se van a utilizar en los
reactivos de esta ecuación entonces
hasta ahí vamos muy bien y finalmente
finalmente
lo que podemos ver es que aquí tenemos 2
oxígenos dos moléculas de oxígeno
gaseoso muy bien y en los productos
tenemos también dos moléculas de oxígeno
entonces piensa como que necesitas de
dos moléculas de oxígeno y después se
liberaron realmente solo fueron como
como que estuvieron presentes para que
se llevara la reacción pero al final se
volvieron a liberar entonces es
realmente como si no hubiéramos
necesitado los oxígenos y qué es lo que
nos queda esencialmente es carbono
sólido más dos moléculas de hidrógeno
gaseoso que al final nos dio metano muy
bien al final nos dio metano y ahí
tienen que si pudimos expresar nuestra
reacción original que está más arriba
esta reacción original la podemos
expresar como la combinación digamos la
suma de estas tres reacciones entonces
aquí es en donde entra la ley de g es
que nos dice qué
el cambio la entalpía de esta reacción
será la suma de los cambios de la
central pías de cada una de estas muy
bien entonces en resumen lo que hicimos
fue expresar esta como suma de otras
reacciones si en esta ecuación 3 tuvimos
que invertir el orden para poder obtener
el metano como producto esta tuvimos que
multiplicarla por 2 para obtener dos
moléculas de hidrógeno que era lo que se
necesitaba en esta original y después
las pudimos expresar como una
combinación o más bien esta reacción
pudimos expresarla como combinación de
estas anteriores así que vamos a
utilizar la ley de hesse para determinar
el cambio en la entalpía de esta
reacción muy bien entonces sacamos
nuevamente la calculadora vamos a quitar
esto y tenemos menos 390 y 3.5
- 570 y 1.6 y sumamos 800 90.3 y eso nos
da un resultado de menos 74.8 menos 74.8
kilos por mol para que se dé esta
reacción muy bien entonces como puedes
darte cuenta de esta reacción al final
fue exotérmica y pues tiene mucho
sentido porque hicimos muchas combustión
es para poder llegar a esta reacción
entonces espero que haya sido muy útil
este vídeo y que ahora sepas muy bien
cómo manejar la ley de hesse